I'm a professional day trader and in
this video I will show you the best
trading session of the last month of
lossing profit for 23,000 because if
these buyers aggressive buyers take back
control I want to be out of the market.
I scalp the NASDAQ during the New York
session and managed to close the session
at $50,000
profit. And I did this while I was also
live with my community. And you have
probably seen me trades or called the
markets a lot of times in the chart
fanatic channel or word of wisdom
podcast is aggressive sellers.
>> Yeah.
>> You you coded the algorithm
>> or in the channel of Andre
>> and since then I have received a lot of
requests. So I decided to open access to
my private charting room. So, if you
want to see my advanced order flow
charting sessions live twice a week
where we chart the markets live
together, the link is in the
description. But now, let's start
commenting this last session. Hello
everyone and welcome back to the
channel. As you saw in the intro, this
is the best session of the month of
December. And we are going to commend in
this one the short that I took on NASDAQ
after building $27,500
in profit on the first trades of the
day. Now, we are risking a small amount
of profit, only 3,150
to make an additional
23,000 of profit on the short position
here. What we have in this situation is
the path of least resistance of the
buyers getting completely absorbed. You
can see the punch to the wall I marked
for you and you can see the rewarded
effort of the sellers. Now in this case
we have complete control on the auction
of the sellers. We are really high in
the curve and I was considering
increasing additional position to
contract on the way down. But the price
was so aggressive that I could only
position myself in discount and is not
the best idea when you are already
loaded with 10 contracts here to raise
the exposure low in the curve. As you
can see the big sellers are in control
of the market. Now the first step that I
will do, I will lower my risk to be
above the eye or a stop to zero and run
this train on the way down trailing
aggressively my stop loss when I see
that buyers might take back control. As
of now, sellers are controlling
completely the auction and we have a
clean level on the 25,650
of control of the sellers. We can see
that they are tapping back into it. the
level 25,7630.
It's controlled by the sellers. You have
an aggressive sell order there. They did
another punch to the wall. And this
could be a level where we cover ourself
is if the market decide to break again
the low. This is an aggressive trailing
stop that I take when we have already a
nice floating profit. Now we are
floating $8,000 in profit on top of the
27,000 already for the day. So it could
could be an idea to be aggressive in
this case. We see if they break the low
the total riskto-reward to get to the
low of the curve is like 1 to 16 1 to 19
on the final target. Let's see how much
it is precisely. Final target is 27,600
for 1 to 19 risk-to-reward. This is not
common. You need volatility to do these
kind of trades. And unfortunately,
volatility is not there every day. So if
you want a smoother profit, you can
decide to take profit more often than I
do when we are in a consolidation phase.
Now I'm waiting to cover myself. I put
my stop loss in profit for $2,550.
And as you can see, the buyers are
trying to reload their position and
reach the 25,630
around there. So, they want to reload on
this position on the way up. Let's see
how it goes.
Back up on the level, reloading on the
sell, aggressive movement. And from
here, you can see the sellers taking
back control. They are absorbing all the
buy orders and the momentum is kicking
back in. As you can see, the candles are
getting wider and they are in the
direction of the auction. Zero doubt
here. There was no fight of the buyers
to break this level. They got absorbed
and immediately sellers took back again
the upper end and we are going to
explode and collapse on the same
direction of the auction because now we
are still high in the curve. So we can
expect still a lot of volatility on this
movement. We are floating $10,000
in profit for the session. This one it's
half almost half of the profit that we
expect from this trade. So if you were
in loss for the day, for example, let's
say minus 5,000, it will be smart to
take profit and to bring your balance
back to break even so you can take a
next trade in a calm way. In this case,
considering that we have $27,000 profit
plus $12,000 profit floating for the
day. Doesn't make sense to be super
conservative on the profit taking. The
market is moving in a really sharp way
and directional. Now they are testing
back the 25,63
and this is where we can expect the
sellers to take back control. For
reference all these sessions and a lot
of session that we did live I always
explain every single move why it's
happening and who is controlling price
and to do this I use orderflow. They are
breaking the level 25,584.3
taking back control. They are super
aggressive on the down move and we are
reaching the value area low of the
session. We are reaching the cluster as
you can see of absorbed sellers and
control of the buyers. They are going to
reload 25,584.
That is the level that I marked. And as
you can see sellers taking back control
again, taking back control again. Here
they go. Now they are starting to
struggle on the way down because you
have absorption of the sell aggressive
orders here and I marked for you the
level of the squeeze that is the level
that if the market managed to break this
low at 25,570
this small range that is creating now
you can expect volatility on the way
down. So you can expect the market to
reach really fast the yellow level that
I marked for you. They are reloading
from the white level that I marked
25,584.
And now you can expect control back of
the sellers. In this case, I was still
in the market with the full 10 contracts
for 176 and 500,000
profit. Now I put my stop loss to
stopping profit for $9,600. So worst
case scenario, we close 36 $37,000.
And now the market, as you can see, is
getting back momentum on the way down.
It's really the size on the direction it
wants to take. see a little bit of
absorption on the level but still the
buyers are not holding the movement and
now it's a really important level it's
the 25,550
this is also a psychological level we
are low in the curve we are in the last
point of absorption and we reach the
level where I mark squeeze that is where
the catalyst will happen in this case so
I cover myself for $20,000 in profit on
the single position and now I I'm
playing with the stopping profit because
I was not sure where to put it because I
don't see participation of the
aggressive traders big orders from the
buy side and sell side and I have the
first clue as you can see I have an
aggressive traders on the sell side on
the bottom that got absorbed so I'm
waiting for him to be recovered and
break on the way down to cover myself
above the last point of break as you can
see sellers trying to load back again to
load momentum on the way up mark the
level 2534
they break I put myself 21,000 in
profit. They try to test. They fail on
the way up. They are still closed in the
last point of aggression of the sellers.
And as you can see, take control back of
the sellers with aggressive buyers. So I
close my stop loss in profit for 23,000
because if these buyers, aggressive
buyers take back control, I want to be
out of the market. And this is how the
session finished. So this one it's my
interactive broker account. You can see
the skew of the single session of the
profit. And this can let you understand
the incredible skew between the maximum
draw down on the single position and
profit. And this is what you can do when
the market is really directional. If you
know how to trail your stop- loss and
how to get the maximum out of the move.
This is the equity line of the single
session. So, as you can see, we started
with a small stop-loss for 3,500 and
then we completed the session with a 10x
risk-to-reward multiplier. Thank you for
watching this video. If you want to see
more of this, let me know in the
comments. I will see you in the next
video and in the live sessions.